let's go next to our caller from the
eight/three - area code caller from 8:30
- what's your name and where are you
calling from Hagen sent me yes it is oh
hi David
big fan thank my name is Luis Castillo
whisk us to you I just have a question
I've noticed in the press briefings the
presidential press briefings yeah I was
and I was just wondering do you know if
there are any progressive journalists in
those press briefings like because I
know I mean I know I don't know what
Network they're from but well they do
say the network they're from but I was
just wondering do you know of any of
them if they're any journalists like
from a progressive news network there
well it depends on what you call
progressive I mean the the journalists
that are there are not at least supposed
to be opinion people the oen people
obviously are right-wing loons there are
people who say oh and CBS or left-wing
but of course the the people that are
there like you know Caitlyn Collins is
there for CNN I don't know her personal
politics I know adversarial
relationships exist between CNN and and
the Trump administration right now but I
don't know the politics of all the
people in the room because they're not
they're really supposed to be there as
reporters not as politically biased
individuals oh I see so so okay so like
the oen would be like the exception I
guess to the rule because I noticed that
it's do typically this young lady and
she doesn't even sit around yeah she's
absolutely bonkers her name is chanel
reown she she doesn't even understand
the questions she's asking she gets this
vacuous look in her eyes where she like
she has an idea of a question and I
don't know if she has it written down
but you can tell she's having trouble
parsing the grammar of her own question
in her mind like she doesn't even know
what she's saying it's all very very
weird but for the most part what you
have is you know like Reuters has a
reporter there The Associated Press
these are people who obviously they have
personal political views but they're not
really supposed to be part of their role
as as part of the White House press
corps
oh wow okay would you ever pick it
someone like you ever considered or
being that be considered to be in that
room I can't no I can't imagine they
would ever grant me a grant me a press
pass loose I'm gonna let you go okay
your your audio is a bit problematic but
I I think I'm the last person that is
going to be allowed into the press room
and certainly if I were I don't think
I'd be allowed to to ask a question
let's go to our caller from the nine
five four area code who's calling today
from 954 David hey Derek what's going on
with Florida you are in the epicenter of
coronavirus that's right give me one
second okay take your time
[Laughter]
lots going on there
sounds like a running I mean yes hey
sorry so yes but wanted to hear your
take on the the 1d shooting with a
Rashard Brooks and whether the charges
are justified listen I I don't I don't
know I don't know that my position is
the same as with the George Floyd case
which is I don't know what the right
charges are we have a system I'm not a
prosecutor I'm not a lawyer I can look
at stuff and sort of say what happened
was wrong but in terms of the charges
there's strategy that goes into charges
there's evidentiary considerations I I
don't know what the right charges are
and that's similar to what I said in
terms of the charges against Derek
shavon and the other officers I think
you know you really only know in
retrospect whether the charges were the
right charges and it has to do with the
evidence it has to do with a lot of
different things I just don't know the
answer mmm
so do you think it was too quick for the
Atlanta DA to bring charges think it was
just like a day and a half
they had like a special investigation
I'm really just don't know all of these
things are it's speculation from the
outside sometimes investigations happen
very quickly sometimes they don't I
think we're just not going to know
until more time goes by
well my take on it yeah I think this is
one that upsets people and it's very
gray zone you know the media was saying
that he was sleeping well
really he was drunk the media said he
was unarmed but I mean he stole the cops
Pazar fired a cop and then the media
said he was nonviolent before arresting
him if you talk to any Sandling who's
lost a life to DUI
I'm sure they'll say that the violent
crime so you're saying that the fact
that he was potentially going to drive
drunk is an act of violence in a sense
court yeah I don't think that's actually
going to that that's a debate that is
not unique to this case I don't believe
that's actually going to be the
determining factor the guy was running
away he wasn't driving away so the fact
that we can debate whether driving drunk
is a violent act I don't think is going
to play a big role in what ultimately
happens okay yeah I appreciate it all
right my friend thank you I appreciate
the phone call uh let's go to a break
that's all the time I have for today
as always I apologize I was not able to
get to everybody but we will take calls
again